Don just provided examples of a good
conceptual model. And an ineffective conceptual model,
using the two refrigerators at Udacity. We'll
talk more about why the ineffective example, was
ineffective in a moment. But first, let's
step back. And talk about what conceptual models
are. So a conceptual model is an
explanation. Usually highly simplified, of how something works.
Sometimes conceptual models are inferred from a
product itself. Sometimes they're learned over a, a
course of time. In other situations they're passed
down from person to person. They're really good
at helping people predict, how something will work.
And what to do in case something goes
wrong. I think conceptional models will like a
lot more sense, if I provide an example.